hallo zusammen das ist Queen day zu
Mineral Reportage Job und Kind zu
welchem Preis es hat ganz viel
Reaktionen
sie sind und das ganz viel vor ihrem
Modell berichten
danke für diese interessante Doku ich
bin jung-mutter geworden mit
mein Kind drei Monate alt ist arbeite
ich 100%. heute mit fast 30 Jahren bin
ich einfach nur müde müde vom
dauerarbeiten und vom Druck genug Geld
zu verdienen und ich finde das ist mega
wichtiges Thema wo man unbedingt anders
aussprechen es gibt einfach auch ganz
viel Familien oder Einzelpersonen wo
drauf achten
dass sie münzgehalt bringen und wo nicht
könnt auswählen
Sie sich gerne
stimmt sondern einfach 100% schaffen
dass die Familie kennt er nähere und was
man auch wichtig ist zu wenig Zimmer
Altersvorsorge gerade Zahl von der
Altersarmut die Frau ist um einiges
höher als die Männer und da dazu hat
Maria von den Kommentar geschrieben das
ist eine Frage ob man wieder arbeiten
möchte damit wir Frauen finanziell
unabhängig bleiben gibt es keine andere
Möglichkeit ich habe von mir das zehn
Jahren aufgehört zu arbeiten und bin
jetzt finanziell völlig von meinem Mann
abhängig ich würde es niemandem
empfehlen
was hier nicht so gesagt wird es tut
auch gut mit Kind mal rauszukommen
Arbeit ein anderes Umfeld andere
Ansprechpersonen und Wertschätzung zu
erfahren das ist ein bisschen
Protagonistinnen
denn er hat sich auch ganz viele
Kommentare
zum Beispiel Ideen Kommentar vielen Dank
für den Film ich denke es braucht
endlich auch Lösungen aus der Politik
Elternzeit von mindestens einem Jahr für
beide Partnerinnen eine Reduktion der
Wochenarbeitszeit und eine bessere
Finanzierung von Kitas das Thema wo aus
war mal sind Männer und zwar schiebt
dort Gabi wieso habt ihr das Thema Job
und Kind wieder nur zum Frauenthema
gemacht wenn es ein Frauenzimmer bleibt
wird es sich nie ändern solange wir
Vereinbarkeit als Frauenthema
zementieren wird sich nie etwas ändern
also vorab mal gesagt ich bin natürlich
Automatik das für e-barkeit bei dir bis
agott Frauen und manner im Film habe ich
einfach so nach wie möglich am inneren
Lebens
wo der perfekt die Lifestyle und das
perfekte die perfekte verübbarkeit und
unser tragen und mir ist einfach wichtig
sie mal es realsbild zeigen wirklich im
Alltag ist ungeschönt und wo immer muss
irgendetwas bewiesen und darum habe ich
mich entschieden
aber ich fand es aus mega spannendes
Thema mal mit ähm
wo 100% schaffen und mit ihnen darüber
reden wie sie sich so fühlen zu dem
Thema Petra und Kommentar geschrieben
und zwar ich frage mich einfach immer
wieder weshalb Väter kam ein schlechtes
Gewissen oder Mühe damit haben ihre
Kinder nur abends oder am Wochenende zu
sehen dass sie hochprozentig arbeiten
nur wir Frauen haben damit ich glaube es
ist schon so dass Frauen mehr müde mit
Hand aber man muss natürlich auch
aufpassen dass man nicht verallgemeinert
auf weitere wo Schwierigkeiten dass sie
dich hinten
ich glaube ich sehr viele Gedanken
darüber gemacht und ich habe schon
vorstellen
die bändig wo sie automatisch von der
Natur sind weil sie das Kind solange
sich immer drei kennt sollte natürlich
dafür dass es Frauen vielleicht die
schwierige fallt und natürlich auch die
Muster und die Rolle Bilder wo mir
verflucht bekommen
betone ist dass es mehr auf gar keinen
Falls mit dem vielen Frauen unter Druck
setzen oder Frauen Geschlechts Gewissens
machen es geht mir darum ein Realität
aufzuzeige und wenn man merkt hey tone
hat einiges noch nicht so gut dann ist
das einfach auch ehrlich über das zu
reden
die Kinderzeit ist eine sehr kurze Zeit
lasst sie euch nicht stillen alles kann
warten aber diese Zeit kriegt niemals
wieder ich hatte das große Glück meine
vier Kinder rund um die Uhr zu genießen
leider hat dieses Privileg fast keine
Mutter mehr
und eigentlich unterstütze ich alles was
sie dem Kommentar gesagt wird findet
weil es gibt bestimmt auch Vater wo es
schätzen würdet Filme zieht mit einer
Kind verbringe oder Kind auch mit ihren
Vater und das würde ja dann auch müttere
dazu bringen dass sie mich
entscheidend
Alleinerziehende Person gezeigt wird ich
habe mir das überleid für den Film
entschieden
dass sie mündlich schaffen zum Geld
verdienen und dass mir das nicht so gut
drauf vergleichen wollen
mit mir genau ich kann es aber super
Input malen Film über das machen wo denn
nur alleine ziehen die Personen
vorkommen weil ich mich vorstellen dass
es da sehr viel hör
t und sehr viel Schwierigkeiten und auch
emotionale Sache wo die Leute
beschäftigen
mich macht das Thema Kinderbetreuung im
Moment wahnsinnig traurig auch teilweise
die Kommentare hier zum Beispiel reden
alle von Arbeitspause Familienarbeit hat
ja schon nach Pausen aber es ist eben
auch Arbeit diese Arbeit wird nicht
genug geschätzt und egal ob als Eltern
oder als Kleinkinder Betreuer
im verlaufenden Film habe ich ganz oft
gemerkt dass es halt schon aus der
Sprachgebrauch ist wo vielleicht einiges
könnt die andere und schon mache
wie man mit der Thematik umgehend so ist
zum Beispiel ganz oft der Fall dass man
müttere oder auch vatere seit am Freitag
bist du nicht am schaffen wenn die
Personen denn ihre Tagen
und irgendwie ist das ja auch wieder
falsch
vor ihrem Bruder aber sie sind durchaus
auch schaffen und darum findest du so
wichtig dass man
arbeitet und was ich auch merkt dann ich
habe ihm im Film workings kam und bin
einfach aufmerksam gemacht wurde dass
das eigentlich ein Begriffe schon völlig
veraltet ist weil es retten zum Beispiel
auch immer von working Deads und darum
habe ich mich dann entschieden
das Schlimmste ist wenn eine Mutter
nicht arbeitet
das sieht dann jeder als komisch an das
ist traurig das ist doch super das Beste
wenn es für alle stimmt und finanziell
geht dann denken alle die hat ja nichts
zu tun es gibt genauso viel Arbeit
Kinder und Haushalt ist genau das mache
ich jetzt gerade vorne gemeint haben
findest du wichtig zu betonen dass es
mir überhaupt nicht darum Gott Frauen
Vorwurf zu machen wo 100% Kind betreut
ich hatte größte Respekt vor mir Mami wo
vier Kinder
umgangen
ich würde sie meinen Kindern schenken
war in Wahrheit die schönste Zeit in mir
geschenkt wurde das finde ich eigentlich
nur schönste Zitat sondern damit
abschließen und was ich noch gesagt ist
ich finde es einfach so schön wenn man
nicht urteilen
zusammenhält
fragen
könnte das aussieht Liebe und abonniere
doch diese Kanal für ganz viel mit